quickly doubling Aldridge down here's  Dellin le with a floater  it's working in China George Leigh Mills  [Applause]  xxx been attempts traffic attention  attention the trailing go  oh and another gentleman three turtles  in a row here for the Thunder  [Applause]  marco Belinelli well points here in this  first half for Ferguson not known for  his shooting Botox is the Hulbert eyes  why the top three-point shooters in the  NBA here kind of take over offenses Lee  here for Billy Donovan in the Thunder  it's got the ice cream pops the plays  wide at three-point shooting ethical  gray cigar clock show what a shock it  defies the other way in January so far  three outside  [Music]  he cannot miss nor can the Spurs overall  that's a fork screaming  [Applause]  they're well over 50% here  there's another three and the Spurs are  12 of 12 from beyond the arc  Buster's began what a fourth that he's  gone six of six 1313 three-point  shooting for 15 in Memphis times  [Applause]